hello everybody thank you so much for
coming it's a beautiful weather and a
beautiful campus so thank you for
spending your after lunch time here I'm
going to be talking about some of the
work in personal informatics and
development of solutions for personal
health thank you for the introduction it
was pretty much covers every every
experience that I've had I did mention
that I my original background was in
shipbuilding engineering which people
find hilarious ask me later when the
transition was like but I did make a
transition from CS and HCI into
biomedical informatics where I am now
and that kind of shapes a little bit my
research but a lot of the questions I
ask are still about how people engage
with technology in the space so I will
start by mentioning briefly the kinds of
things that I will not be talking about
but we'll be happy to answer questions
being in the medical school a part of my
work it was and continues to be on
understanding clinical work practices
particularly communication and
collaboration among clinicians within
patient care teams I am listing some
papers here this was a work of my
recently graduated PhD students I will
not be talking about any of this here
but I'm happy to answer questions and a
little bit earlier I talked about some
of the work on collective sense making
within online health communities again
this is a big part of my what my
research is focusing on but this will be
outside of the topic for this
presentation what I do want to talk
about today is this big problem that
this country and many countries around
the world face is the continuous growth
in chronic conditions and chronic
diseases by now I think the statistics
are well known to everybody it continues
to be a big challenge and one of the big
problems in chronic diseases is that
they require continuous and proactive
self management from affected
individuals so here I'm listing seven
health care behaviors identified by the
American diet Association of die
various educators healthy eating being
active monitoring taking medication
problem-solving reducing risk and
healthy coping so that's a relatively
comprehensive set of activities that
somebody with diabetes needs to engage
it in on daily basis and given the scale
of this problem there are a large number
of efforts in many different communities
to address this problem Columbia has a
wonderful Department of Public Health
there are a large number of public
health initiatives that focused on
communication education there are many
technological solutions from both
commercial side the industry and also
the academia research and on health
technologies has grown exponentially
with in HCI and computer science as well
but what we see is that despite all
these efforts there are moderate impact
and there are still relatively low
levels of engagement people find it
difficult to engage with technologies
for management of chronic conditions now
health behaviors is a large space and
there's a lot of work going on from
different sides and it's also very rich
theoretically space so when you start
thinking about technologies in health
management a good place to start is with
theories of health behaviors there exist
many different theories I find this
particular one to be helpful not only
because it suggests opportunities for
where to intervene but also it presents
a relatively good way to think about
kind of the directions for research and
outline the space of solutions so to
engage in health behaviors several
preconditions need to be met people need
to understand what those behaviors are
and be knowledgeable they also need to
be motivated and have a motivation to
engage in those behaviors they need to
be able to translate this general
knowledge into their specific behaviors
and overcome barriers
then all of this leads to engagement in
behaviour now if you think of it this is
also again a good way to think about
different research areas there is a lot
of work in public health on knowledge
lead knowledge and health literacy
nutritional literacy a lot of papers
written about this there is a vast
bodies of work in motivation and how to
intervene on motivation behavior change
is a rich field a paper recently came
out that listed almost a hundred of
active behavior change modification
techniques there's less but still some
work on behavioral skills and how to
translate general guidelines into daily
behaviors and there is a little bit less
on translating this into actual actions
but in my lab by now we a lot of our
work focuses on diabetes self-management
and a lot of it is about nutrition and
managing nutrition and by now we've
interviewed probably more than a hundred
people of day with diabetes and there
are some things that keep coming up that
don't quite fit with this overarching
framework or push it a little bit in new
directions so one thing we're finding
repeatedly is that general knowledge of
nutrition does not necessarily guarantee
self management of diabetes just knowing
that it's good for everybody to eat more
fruits and vegetables does not
necessarily mean you're going to manage
your diabetes well it's a very
individual disease a lot has been
written in the last few years actually
about dramatic differences in
individuals reaction glycemic reaction
to nutrition and meals this means that
in addition to general knowledge there
is a high need for individual discovery
figuring out how a one's own body reacts
to nutrition Plus even when we do that
when individuals can do that health is
only one of the consideration that
drives choices in their regular life
there are many other
priorities financial considerations
access social cultural preferences taste
preferences all of those things need to
be considered when making lifestyle
choices we were talking earlier today
how pushing in the health direction at
the expense of taste convenience social
influences may lead to burnout and
decreased quality in life and ultimately
this solutions are not sustainable in
the long run and then there is a lot
written also on the gap between
intentions in actions so there's a lot
of cognitive interference people are
busy in their daily lives
so having good intentions does not
necessarily lead to following through on
those intentions at the act of at the
time of action so one way to think for
me and for my lab about this is to think
about the choices that people make in
the context of their nutrition I don't
know how you make nutritional choices
but I typically think about what am I in
the mood for what's available for me
what's convenient yesterday I was on the
flight from New York I thought I fancy
sushi today there was a great lunch and
that was kind of what the choices were
and it was easy to settle into some
decisions but if you have diabetes that
Chuy's become incredibly more
cognitively complex because the question
here becomes what should I eat that is
healthy for me personally which means
it's not going to throw my blood glucose
levels off too much that fits my budget
fits my preferences fits my social
constraints consisted with my cultural
preferences and the list goes on and on
and on and when you think about it
making these kinds of choices requires a
lot of mental acrobatics so if what
would it means to self-manage diabetes
is to engage in that three times a day
for breakfast lunch and dinner
every day no wonder there is a lot of
burnout it's extremely cognitively
complex and perhaps that's why there is
a reason to intervene on motivation so
much because it takes a very motivated
individual to do that consistently and
I'm going to show you a scary slide but
I'll explain it it's actually there
there is a simple message here so in my
lab we we spend a lot of time thinking
about how people engage with complex
problems like self management of
diabetes and how they make sense of it
so this is a framework that resulted
from some of the qualitative studies and
the main idea here is that when you
apply sense-making as a paradigm to
chronic disease self-management it
suggests that people tend to operate is
something that's called habitual mode we
don't like to spend much time and much
cognitive effort on simple solutions
such as choice of meals and we would
rather spend our cognitive efforts on
something that is more important
personally meaningful and then people
only engage cognitively when they really
have to
so reflection problem-solving are very
expensive cognitively activities and the
question or the challenge for my lab and
in my research has become to think of
solutions computational solutions that
help to reduce cognitive complexity of
health management and the way we've
started thinking about this is going
from helping structure people's thinking
helping them with tools that make it
easier to reflect and learn and then go
into doing some of the reflection and
learning computationally and helping
individuals make decisions to even
further their way to guiding their
actions with small and simple
recommendations but not surprisingly any
kind of decrease in cognitive complexity
for people is at the expense of X
increase of computational complexity of
the solutions that we're building and
this is where we're starting to think
about this transformation from personal
informatics when we expect individuals
to do a lot of the reflection and
thinking and discovery to solutions that
do a lot of that for them and provide
them with decision support and action
support and I'll show you examples for
what I what we mean by those in the way
we do it is with a lot of self
monitoring data and now with a lot more
data science that we can yes we can
incorporate don't worry about cooking oh
yes so back to the discussion that we
had earlier a lot of this work also is
driven by careful consideration of the
issues of autonomy I think to the degree
possible we would like to maintain
people in charge and in control and I
feel much more comfortable with
solutions that lay out the options and
help them choose the option that's more
appropriate for them rather than guiding
them towards choices that somebody else
thought were better for them so that's
why there is a I think we're trying to
make this into more of a decision
support rather than into behavior
modification so there are three areas
that I'm going to be talking about there
are several examples of how we thought
we could support reflection and learning
and then what we did within making
decisions and also how we started moving
more into supporting action and a little
bit about my approach to research I
academically speaking grew up and HCI
traditions so a lot of what our oil
would was used to be called experimental
computer science
a lot of what I do is develop novel
technologies novel design solutions test
them in pilot studies to see is this a
good idea how does how do people
resonate with that what kind of
engagement it inspires but I'm also the
medical school which is very concerned
with health impact so every once in a
while we develop more comprehensive
solutions test them in clinical trials
with hundreds of people to actually look
at whether or not the solutions lead to
change in health and just for fun we
also occasionally study a adoption of
technologies in the wild so we did throw
some of our technologies on Appstore to
see how they're adapted in without in
outside of the context of research
studies so back to this this is also
going to be the transition here from
more of well developed solutions with
some of the outcomes and clinical
studies to more newer solutions where
we've done some feasibility studies but
don't really know whether they lead to
changes in health to some of the newer
ideas where we started conceptualizing
but haven't quite gone through
evaluation yet so this is more of a
future work area all right so let's
start with reflection and learning and
the first thing here again we're in this
space of helping people answer the
question of what's a good meal for me
we're working with diabetes there are
some other things that we've done but
I'll focus on this here if we can help
people reflect on their past and answer
this question how can we do that the
first thing that we've tried was to
model the cognitive process so if you
think about it if somebody needs to
perform something cognitively
challenging one way to make it easier it
is to suggest the process for how to do
that so back to that example of
multiplying two large numbers there is a
multiplication algorithm it doesn't make
it very easy but it makes it easier than
trying to make do it in your head so if
we want our individual stool with
diabetes to reflect on their experiences
with nutrition is there a process that
they can follow and how can we guide
them through this process so this was a
relatively large project this was funded
by the National Institute of Diabetes
and digestive and kidney disease it was
a large clinical trial and it is
available online so if you're interested
you can take a look at it and play with
it the idea there is that there exist
several frameworks that discuss describe
how this process of reflection and
problem-solving works and include
certain number of steps and we could
build an interactive solution to model
this process for individuals so here are
the steps identify problems and glycemic
control keep track of your blood glucose
levels and notice where during the day
your numbers are not where they're
supposed to be identify behavioral
triggers what are some of the behaviors
that may be contributing to the glycemic
problems and I'll talk in a second about
how we did this set goals for corrective
actions you there are certain behaviors
that cause disruption and glycemic
control change behaviors and then see
whether there they're changing blood
glucose levels but because this was
meant to be used by individuals from
medically underserved low-income
communities low access to technology and
low familiarity with technology we
wanted to make it very simple
technologically so there was not much
behavioral tracking in this and this
identifying behavioral triggers we
didn't have any data on what individuals
actual behaviors were so instead we used
a knowledge engineering approach we
worked with diabetes educators and
identified a set of diabetes
self-management behaviors that are known
to trigger blood glucose changes in
blood glucose so when our users looked
at their blood glucose levels and
identified problems we've presented them
with the list of possible behavioral
triggers and asked them now think about
your own behaviors are you engaging in
any of this so
the thinking still needed to happen in
their heads we just gave them the
structure for how to think about it
and because it was meant to be a
clinical trial we billed it as a
relatively comprehensive solution one
thing we've discovered and keep
discovering every year is that there is
a big difference between testing proof
of concept prototypes and developing
clinically effective solutions that
individuals can engage with over a long
period of time so Maude had a lot of
different things it had motivational
messages it had action plans for
achieving goals and a set of reminders
for following through on goals so these
are preliminary results which mean that
it worked actually it did make some
change
perhaps not groundbreaking but it had an
impact and we also did qualitative
analysis or qualitative studies twice
one was with a random subset of
participants of the trial and then we
found we noticed that actually almost by
accident that after the trial was
completed there is a part of our
participants who are still using it
today every day which was an incredible
discovery we don't pay them we don't
they're not in the study anymore they're
done officially and they're still using
it so we wanted to understand why one of
the things that came out very strongly
is that different people had very
different way of engaging with this for
some of them it was the personal goals
that were a really powerful mechanism
they really like setting goals and then
working towards their goals for others
they never said a single goal throughout
the whole study so they ignored that
whole goal-setting aspect of it but what
it had it had one screen that showed
them trance in their blood glucose
levels and they started using those as a
way for situational awareness it was a
very nice way one of the participants
described it is that he developed a
routine he would wake up in the morning
look at his weather forecast to see
weather take an umbrella or how to dress
and then he would look at Maude to see
how he is doing blood glucose levels
wise and how to his
a bit high then maybe go easier on meals
during the day or if he is running low
maybe that's a good way to have a good
lunch and then for others it was this
idea of being in the program was very
interesting it was almost cult-like
description of this where it was the set
of reminders that created a structure
for individuals to engage in self
management and stay within that what
didn't work however is the process of
reflection most everybody felt that it
was too difficult to sit down and took a
lot of effort to kind of think about
their past and think about their
experiences
it was very cognitively challenging and
that sort of drove us that was one of
the reason that started driving us in
this direction of reducing cognitive
complexity so switching gears a little
bit but still yes how they saw
themselves like probably I'm capable of
tracking to not be incapable or like I'm
a good looked at self-efficacy
definitely there is a scale of self
efficacy and diabetes still analyzing
results so I can comment on that but yes
we had quality of life measure diabetes
depression measure self-efficacy and one
of our main criteria which is
unfortunately extremely difficult to
analyze is the problem-solving abilities
in diabetes so that's still in in the
works we're hoping to have the results
imminently so one of the problems with
this was with this solution was this
idea of I have to reflect on my own
behaviors I have to go back in my memory
and think about what is it that I do
well the question became all right we
don't have to ask people to do that we
have all this self tracking technologies
why don't we just track things for them
and this was a work of my student Daniel
Fowler who was interested in
visual analytics approaches and his
thought was let's track everything and
let's develop visual solutions for
people to know it observe the data and
perhaps analyze their associations
between daily activities and changes in
blood glucose levels but because we
suspected that this was going to be a
tricky proposition and because
historically we're working and because
of where our Hospital is located we are
in again predominantly first-generation
immigrant low socioeconomic status
community aware complex computational
solutions are not necessarily the best
way to go so we thought we would start
with professionals and he developed a
tool for dieticians
to examine patient self monitoring data
and identify those trends who has seen a
hit map before all right fair number pop
all right so this is a typical heat map
that is used in a lot of generic
analysis each row here represents a meal
each column represents a particular
variable related to this meal so here
amount of carbohydrates protein fat
fiber and the change in blood glucose
before and after meal and this is a real
data set it was collected by an
individual with type 2 diabetes the
color indicates the amount off or the
value of the variable so red means a lot
white means average and blue means very
little off so here the idea for this
representations was to help dietitian
notice there are changes in color
between macronutrients and changes in
blood glucose levels and it was designed
as an interactive tool they could do a
lot of things with it they can sort the
data set by different columns they could
select particular types of meals to look
at and here we started introducing some
computational analysis techniques they
could also use hierarchical clustering
to group meals based on their nutrition
and on their glycemic impact but I'll
talk about that a little bit later
but the whole idea here was to help them
notice that well there is a group of
meals at the top where they're very red
on carbohydrate very blue on protein and
fat and very red on blood glucose change
so that means for this person meals with
high carbohydrate low fat and protein
are not working very well and then there
is another group of blue carbohydrate
red protein fat and blue blood glucose
are much better meals so these are the
patterns were the trends we expect them
to be able to see from this view and we
ran a study where we invited ten
registered dietitians we showed them two
different data sets one with our tool
one with this more or less table like
presentation where they would see a
picture they would see nutrition on the
meal and the change in blood glucose
before and after and the caveat here
that the data sets been between 60 and
120 meals this kind of view involves a
lot of scrolling scrolling scrolling
scrolling so it's a long data set and we
try to we ask them to generate patterns
identify patterns and then we compared
what kind of patterns came up from two
different tools what we found and I'm
moving through the results relatively
quickly but there is a paper on this
also you can you can see more there is
that using our tools dieticians were
able to identify more patterns without
any reduction and accuracy and the
parents were on more patterns about not
carbohydrates so the association between
carbohydrates and blood glucose levels
is very well known and understood and
basically with the tabular
representation that was the only thing
that dietitians saw with a glue Collider
with our tool they were able to see more
of the data set and they were able to
see other patterns that may not be as
obvious at the beginning but they're
clearly yes whether a particular pattern
is a correct pattern or a useful pattern
very interesting question so I'll get to
it a little bit later a lot of the
things that we do now have to do with
computational discovery in which case
whether it's a correct pattern is a very
very hard question to answer we don't
have very good ways of knowing what's
true about the world except for maybe
have a gold standard which is this
exactly it's having experts identify
those patterns so here we didn't even
try asking the question of what's the
real pattern there because there's no
way of knowing that but we did ask them
to try to focus on clinically meaningful
patterns patterns that could help them
to generate recommendations for their
participants so the two things that came
out as challenges here is one every time
I show the first heat map I see faces
and the audience go it is a complex tool
it took an hour of training for our
dieticians to understand how it works
and they wished for more so we can't
even dream of showing something like
this to our participants patients with
diabetes and then another thing that
came out as a result of this work is
that we discovered an interesting term
apophenia who has heard this before all
right usually I don't have anybody who
knows this so this is a term that is
used a lot and cognitive psychology to
describe human tendency to see patterns
in chaos as it turns out as humans we
like our world to be organized
I hope this definition is consistent
with how you know it but there is a
tendency we will like to see patterns we
like our world to be predictable and
there is a tendency again to impose
structure and patterns on something that
may not have any structure in it there
has been a lot of work there was a lot
of work in the 80's and 90's to show how
individuals may use visualizations of
data to identify completely none exists
that correlations between different
variables so it's a tricky proposition
to show somebody to visualize data for
individuals and expect them to identify
through patterns and again this is what
moved us further into the supporting of
making decisions but before we get there
another line of work still in the
reflection has to do with helping
individuals learn from others so so far
I've talked about tools that are
designed to help people learn from their
own experiences but evolutionary
speaking learning from consequences of
one's own actions is a very expensive
way to learn typically speaking we learn
by observing others and consequences of
actions from by others so this is a line
of work that two of my postdocs Marissa
burgomaster and Maria Juan were working
on trying to see how we can leverage
observational learning within with
social computing platforms and the idea
here was to apply it in the context of
learning about nutrition so in diabetes
self-management we're talking a lot
about nutritional choices but to make
nutritional choices first you need to
know something about nutrition you need
to be able to say that what are
carbohydrates what is fat what is
protein and how does it look like an
estimate how much of it is on the plate
so we applied this observational
learning to these kinds of questions and
we did two studies one was done in
crowdsourcing environment with our
workers and Amazon Mechanical Turk where
we gave them an image of a meal we gave
them all the ingredients in the meal and
we asked them to map ingredients with
macronutrients so what are beans is that
carbohydrate is it fat is a protein is
it fiber and then we asked them to do it
and then we also showed them how other
workers answered that question
and distribution of opinions within the
community of crowd workers and our hope
was that by exposing them to opinions of
others we can help them
learn and improve the accuracy of their
own choices the second study was done
and I'll talk about the results in a
minute at the second study of a similar
nature but slightly different was done
with the lab in the wild it's a platform
for open platform for social experiments
run by researchers at Harvard University
this was a collaboration with Christophe
Gaia's it's a collaborative set of
researchers but we worked with him
specifically and there we showed
individuals two images and we asked them
which meal is higher in particular
macronutrient so again it's a very
common question or choice individuals
with diabetes face which one has more
fiber if I'm supposed to eat meals that
are higher on fiber should I go for the
left one or the right one and again here
we expose them to how others answer that
question as a way of promoting learning
and we compare that with the correctness
feedback from experts which is a typical
way of learning particularly in
educational settings for those of you
who are students you know that you take
tests you get those tests graded by
experts and that's how you learn not to
make where your knowledge may be
insufficient and where you need to
improve it we could with and without
explanations we also used correctness
feedback from peers and observing
answers by peers and that was our way of
observation modeling observational
learning so in a nutshell what we found
in those studies was for these simple
tasks such as match foods vyas makrand
treants observing answers by others did
just as well as receiving correctness
feedback from experts so it really
helped to promote learning but when the
questions were more complex such as
which meal is higher on fiber the only
thing that promoted learning was
explanations so neither correctness
feedback nor observing others changed
anything in individuals ability to
answer those
and it I mean it makes sense if you have
a complex meal like that or complex
question you need to know what
specifically in that meal contributed to
change in macronutrient but we also
found that peer generated explanations
worked just as well as expert generated
ones so all this suggests that
observational learning can be used as a
powerful mechanism in social settings
and we're continuing this line of work
looking how to extend it from generic
meal to individual's own meals but one
of the main sort of conclusions from
this studies was that yes we see some
improvement and yes we see modest but
detectable effects but they're still
cognitively complex only in all of this
experiments that we've conducted in all
of the solutions only the most motivated
individuals actually continued the
engagement for many participants of the
studies it was too hard and they really
didn't want to do this they wanted
something simpler this idea of I just
want to know what you eat for my next
lunch continues to be a theme through
many of the studies we've conducted so
that moved us more into all right fine
let's focus on that let's try to build
tools that help people make decisions
and here we're moving from reflection
and what is a good meal to something
very concrete I'm about to have lunch I
have my meal choices is this a good meal
for me and the way we're doing it is by
again moving a lot of the come
processing and computing from people's
heads and into their computational
inferences with self monitoring data Pro
identifying different ways to provide
decision support and delivering this
decision support at the time of
decisions so this work required a lot of
data science because now we're doing a
lot of the computational inference and
one of the tricky things that we've
discovered very quickly is that the kind
of
we work with breaks machine learning
very fast
it's very sparse there is just not
enough data to make stable inferences
people eat three times a day they don't
repeat the same ingredients every day
so nothing simple that we've tried
worked very reliably that's why we
started looking into much more complex
data science bringing methods from
weather forecasting from control systems
so there's a lot of collaborations and I
can answer some questions about this and
show how we're using these methods in
our systems but the question for my lab
and I think it's more of a h HCI
question is to Lucan well what kind of
decision supports mechanisms can we
provide and I'll just take a quick step
away from the health questions here
because I think these kinds of questions
are going to become more prevalent in
the HCI community I don't know about
Stanford but data science is sweeping
the world of academia Columbia has a
data science Institute Harvard open the
data Science Institute we're talking
about AI now when I was a PhD student
nobody would say that they do work in AI
there is a lot more computational
intelligent intelligence that is
becoming available but the questions of
how do we make this intelligence
available to people what kind of
interactive solutions do we build on it
I think there are many open questions
there and I think we started tackling
some of these questions and health I see
other HCI groups are starting to think
about how do we engage people with
predictions what does it mean to predict
future or predict health outcomes and
again there are a lot of HCI questions
around those topics that I hope we will
be exploring in in the future I see some
questions from the back row there feel
free to jump in so the two things that
we've tried so far are two specific ways
of supporting decisions is generating
computationally generating personalised
goals
helping people assess their choices on
fit with those goals and second is
something that's coming from the theory
of planned behavior is outcomes
expectations and it's forecasting if we
can predict the future
for individuals and show them how their
choices impact their health can that
help them to make decisions in the
future so the first thing we've tried
here was some app developed called
plátano and this is a work of matt
levine and elliot mitchell and the way
it works is that it uses computational
discovery of patterns we're still in the
space of nutrition and diabetes
self-management then what it does it
uses expert system to translate
computational discoveries into
personalized goals and then it uses in
the moment decision support which in
this case takes the form of when
individuals are confronted with a new
meal reminding them about their goal and
asking them to assess their meal on the
feet of their goal and if the meal
doesn't fit the goal suggesting that
they change something about the meal to
make it more consistent with the goal so
from the computational side we use two
different methods we use trio clustering
and we use something which is called
attributable component analysis which is
a fancier version of a principal
component analysis but the whole idea
here is to identify ranges of
macronutrients that have a systemic
impact on blood glucose either mild or
lead to high blood glucose excursions
but the problem here is that even if you
can computationally identify that how do
you make this useful for somebody how do
you inform them showing them graphs like
this is not necessarily the best thing
what does it mean and how to incorporate
that into a decision so here what we did
is we developed a set of heuristics that
would translate those ranges into
nutritional goals formulated in the
natural language
we worked with diabetes educators and
dietitians and we identified that there
are really three things that they could
think of that somebody may want to do to
their meals increase or decrease a
particular macronutrient replace one
macronutrient with another you can say
replace half of your carbs with protein
or because carbohydrates are such a
common offender in diabetes replacing
carbohydrates with what's called three
foods most typically vegetables so these
are the most common things most common
nutritional goals one might have and
what we did is that again that the
expert system said a user uses a set of
decision rules to generate goals that
look like this for high carbohydrate
breakfasts reduce your carbs to be about
one carb choice examples of one curve
choice are one slice of whole wheat
toast one cup of oatmeal or one Apple
it took us exactly two months to come up
with that one sentence because it is a
very tricky thing to come up with
something that is non contradictory to
other nutritional goals short and could
be understood by a person and could be
computed based on the computational
analysis that we're doing and the trick
here is that practically every word in
the sentence is generated using a set of
decision rules so and then again in the
moment decision support I can show you
how it works so we ask our individuals
to our participants to keep track of
their meals they photograph meals we use
a crowdsourcing engine to assign
nutritional composition of the meals and
we ask them to track blood glucose
before and after meals or at some times
during the day to the degree possible
all this data runs through the
computational inference engine through
our expert system generates goal like
this the individuals can ignore them or
choose to work to select those goals and
then when they take a picture of their
new meal the app will pop up a question
is this meal consistent with your goal
yes or no and if the
answer is no the apples just changing
the meal so that it's more consistent
with the goal and it keeps track of goal
achievement rate so we did two studies
to validate these goals first we wanted
to see can people even understand these
goals is it even the feasible
proposition so we did a controlled lab
study with 14 individuals from our
community and we didn't want to mess
with actual meals so we give them food
cut outs but the idea there was to ask
them to compose meals that followed
goals that were generated
computationally three main questions we
had can they understand the goals if we
give them meals and told them what the
nutrition and the meals was can they
pick the right meal for the goal can
they pick the right meal when they don't
know what the nutrition in the meal is
just a picture of a meal and fine which
meal matches the goal so that's a more
difficult question and if we ask them to
follow goals would they do it in the
controlled study setting so notice that
this is not a question will they follow
the goals in their real lives the
question is can they if we ask them to
so for a few weeks my lab turned into
your arts and crafts project where
everybody was cutting food models out of
paper but long story short what we found
in the study is that when individuals
knew what the nutrition in the meal was
they were very good at finding right
meals that match the goals so the very
least they understood what the goals
were when we didn't give them the
nutrition in the meals they were not
very good at finding what meals
match different goals but when we asked
them to follow goals interestingly
enough they were okay when we asked them
to match the goals precisely but they
were very good at moving to work in the
right direction
so they may not have matched the exact
amount of specific macronutrients but
they made the move in the right
direction so that means that the virion
they can understand the goals and if
pressed they can change their nutrition
to follow those goals so we build the
tool we build a smartphone app and we
gave it to 20 individuals and asked them
to use it for four weeks and again this
was a feasibility study so we didn't
look at behavior change and we
definitely didn't look at health changes
we just looked at whether it's a good
idea and can it work what we found is
that there was a I say moderate moderate
level of engagement truth be told this
was a higher level of engagement that
we've seen in any our previous studies
they were pretty consistent taking
pictures of the meals and engaging with
the app it was an interesting
proposition for us because the goals
were generated automatically
so we basically kept track of what they
were and tried to understand are these
reasonable goals and we had a diabetes
educator looking at them and then we
found the goals were generated
relatively quickly so our computational
methods converged on their ranges
relatively quickly
which again we didn't know that that
would happen and then the range of goals
covered almost all macronutrients and
what was interesting is that there were
different degrees of gold stability so
I'll just show you quickly the
transformation of gold for one person
the goals because it keeps track of
individual diet in real time the goals
change not only based on for example
based on changes individuals diet so for
somebody the first goal was to reduce
carbohydrate to about 4 and 1/2 cup
choices on the next week the goal change
to reduce to 4 carb choices so it starts
to as the individual starts to make
changes to their diet the goal start to
be more progressively moving them so
again one thing here is back to the
question of the gentleman in the red
sweatshirt there is how do we know that
these are the right goals the answer is
we don't because there is no truth and
we don't
of knowing truth so we are going to be
running a set of studies in the summer
to at least assess their face validity
and see whether experts would agree with
those but computational discovery always
has a question of whether we're
discovering something that's really
there and then we run a set of
qualitative studies that at the very
least showed that the tool was easy to
use and that there was very positive
reaction to the idea of pausing during
the meal and reflecting on it and
thinking about whether it meets the goal
or not
so that idea was very well received the
personalized goals were also well
received and particularly the idea of
focusing on one macronutrient at a time
this is a very common question am i
doing okay on my carbohydrates do I need
to change my protein so this was
consistent with the kinds of questions
that people had coming into the study
but what came out very strongly is the
need for recommendations let's say this
meal is not consistent with my goal so
what what should I do
there was this consistent question of
give me examples of what kinds of meals
are consistent with my goals
the next question I'll go relatively
quickly through this so this was a
different way of providing decision
support generating personal goals still
required some reflection and thinking
about goals and preparation and we were
looking for a lighter weight engagement
for individual so here what we did the
idea there was to use the metaphor of
weather forecasting and actually use
exactly the same methods that are used
for weather forecasting something called
data simulation combined with the
physiological model of blood glucose
regulation this is again this is the
same type of combination that is used in
weather forecasting weather incoming
streams of data allowed to personalize
parameters of the model yes
automated tool doing it where is it self
blogging right so one of the reasons
actually data simulation works is
because of the sparse data we would not
be able to do this kind of inference
with any other type of statistical
machine learning because there is a lot
of knowledge already embedded in the
mechanistic model that actually allows
to deal in the sparse data environment
in terms of the so another way to the
first set of methods we were using I
don't know how how far I can go in the
computational side so we started with a
common filter where the model learns as
it goes through time so step by step so
this requires quite substantial amount
of initial training data to get to good
results what I think we've started
transitioning into is something that
allows to use simulation Markov chain
Monte Carlo methods to shorten the
training period so there are
computational ways of dealing with
sparse and irregular data sets but it's
still a very complex process and our
data science team is pushing forward
even further in new solutions for that
so very quickly there is a paper that
actually talks about the models itself
and how well it predicts blood-glucose
impact of different meals but again from
the experience and HCI side this is the
tool we built on this so let's say I am
wondering whether I can have two cookies
as a dessert after dinner I can take a
picture of the meal in this case because
I want the forecast right away I myself
enter the nutritional composition the
best I can and then the tool almost
right away within a few seconds give me
gives me a prediction of how my blood
glucose will change if I eat this cookie
if I'd like this forecast great
I'm gonna go hiding in both cookies if I
don't like it I may remove one of the
cookies take another picture generate
another forecast and then they said oh
well one cookie is actually much better
for me so why don't I have one cookie so
again we conducted a qualitative study
of this tool we found with ten
individuals who used it for four weeks
and it is available on App Store so
again if you want to play with it feel
free to download it what we found is
that again it was overall it was an
interesting idea an interesting
proposition the interesting finding here
was that many people used it not in the
way we anticipated so instead of
changing the meal itself they would eat
the meal even if it was a high forecast
but then we would do something else to
compensate for it so they would drink a
lot of water after the meal or they
would go for a walk so they found
alternative compensation strategies but
we also found that engaging people with
predictions is challenging and there are
many questions still open for example
when is the right time to show this
forecast by the time the miu is on the
plate it's kind of too late
many of our participants felt that you
know the moon was already there I'm just
going to eat it and then see a hope for
the best how to present this for a cast
we just showed them the range but what
we actually generate from the model is a
continuous curve so there is a lot more
information we could be showing but the
question is what is the right amount of
it how to show uncertainty there are
many studies that examined how to
communicate uncertainty in weather
forecasts because all computational
predictions come with some degree of
uncertainty in them we just presented a
paper at chi on different ways to
visualize forecasts for individuals and
again there is this need for
recommendations when you have when the
question is one cookie or two cookies
it's a pretty relatively simple decision
to make
but if when it's a complex meal on the
plate and you don't like the forecast
what can you do
so that moved us in the direction from
making decisions to actions can we find
a way to actually make very specific
concrete recommendations that don't
require pondering different options and
don't require quite so much reflection
what should I eat for lunch and the
trick here is there are there's a lot of
work on recommender systems that focuses
on identifying generating
recommendations based on past behaviors
and inferring personal preferences in
the context of chronic disease
self-management
this needs to be married with
physiological inferences because
recommending people something that they
did in the past may or may not be the
right solution so it's a combination of
personal preferences and what's right
from the health perspective and the
recent work in this space was kind of
getting into the space of Alexa what can
I have for lunch who has Alexa or any
other speaking devices at their home
right so you're in the right area for
that so last summer Elliot who is a PhD
student in my lab organized a group of
students and they've built a prototype
which is a Alexa skill combined with the
messenger chain bot t2d - and what it
does it uses exactly the same
computational machinery that we
developed for other two applications to
generate personal goals and then search
nutritional database to extract recipes
that match macronutrient proportions and
the composition that is recommended for
this individual and you can interact
that when a way you can ask what can I
make with chicken and mushrooms because
that's what I have in my refrigerator
right now and it will search through the
database of recipes and we'll send
recipes to our personal cell phone
phone app so they participated in last
summer in the Alexa diabetes challenge
were selected as one of the five
finalists so it was a well received idea
and we're now starting to enter in the
space of user studies to see how would
individuals actually interact with a
tool like that so to wrap this up I
think what I was trying to show here is
that health management is a complex
problem and the space of solutions can
be also very complex we still need to
work on motivation and continue all the
efforts on motivating individuals to
engage in health behaviors but I think
there is a lot more we can do in helping
them to make these decisions easier and
reducing the cognitive complexity and
again I think that these are the kinds
of questions that are going to become
more prevalent not only in health but in
many areas of human lives as we start
engaging with more data science and more
computational inferences
I have very likely to work with many
excellent collaborators and to be well
funded but main credit goes to all the
wonderful students that I've been
working with over the years thank you
[Applause]
like do you know why that is they don't
need complex information that an expert
could provide
more effectively right so I think the
question was what are the reasons why
people learn just as much from expert
generated explanations for them from
peer generated one thing we found is
that and I think this was observed in
educational literature and many other
studies as well is that finding the
right words to explain on the same level
makes a difference expert generated
explanations can sometimes be more
complex than is necessary in a
particular case so we found that peer
generated explanations really went to
the fore the most critical part it's the
fiber or it's the piece and they really
were very short and to the point
expert generated explanations tended to
be a much longer and more complex so I
think part of it is that the just the
language itself made them could make the
difference so this is very interesting
question and I think that works somewhat
differently in regards to something that
is a fact
versus something that is an opinion when
you deal with nutritional facts the fact
that beans are carbohydrates and protein
there's really not much room for
negotiation it is what it is so and we
in our studies so far at least only
dealt with facts but once we get to the
point of what's healthy that's where I
think the kinds of things you're talking
about are going to become much more of
an issue because there can be many
different opinions on that and there
could be much more of a pressure from
peers and from the
mmunity to steer in the particular
direction even with our studies what we
found that if you rely on observational
learning there is a critical period of
formulating the first few opinions and
because of how the studies were
conducted we kind of skipped over at
that time that period but information
cascades is a very well-known phenomenon
in collective intelligence if the first
few opinions steer it in the wrong
direction there is a possibility of the
entire community going in that direction
so it is a it is a real danger there
have been some attempt to address this
problem one there was a work at Georgia
Tech quite some time ago to allow those
who are more confident in their answers
to express their level of consequence so
for example if you an expert and you
know the right answer your opinion could
be weighted higher than if you are kind
of guessing but you are not entirely
sure those opinions could be a rated
lower but it's still open for
exploration mindsets there's some work
here postulated here says that if your
mindset about healthy foods that's
boring it doesn't matter how much you
say all these dead person thing it
continues to be boring and difficult to
really adhere to it you may do it some
apples are beginning you may try to do
it but it continues to be boring and and
suddenly there is also some linguistics
you know research that shows that at
least in the u.s. you know
you look at the menus of like you know I
think that you're asking is a study on
you know thousands of men discovered
that everything that's control or even
the bad things that you're consuming it
comes around very beautiful language in
the menus like seasoning meanwhile the
more the good stuff you know the thing
that you should be doing is like and
broccoli right so it's like this very
boring thing like so it creates this
like no interest from a you know
desirability as opposed to like you know
decision-making which is a bit maybe
more ingrained maybe you you touch this
aspect of like it how people really
relate to food so they're it's a very
interesting question there also have
been studies to show that for example
alerting individuals to caloric
composition of meals can have a very
interesting and different impacts on
different communities I believe there
were studies to show that in low-income
communities it actually we've had the
opposite impact and people opted to buy
more high calorie meals because they
considered those to be a sort of a
better deal for the same amount of money
I think that there is a way to address
that by again combining potentially
individual preferences or modeling of
individual preferences of things that
people already like and enjoy and rely
on with some of wareness of health
implications what's really and even if
you talk to diabetes educators I think
one of the ideas there is making small
changes so not necessarily
reconceptualizing
how people think about diet and
nutrition but operating within the same
set of references but with small
adjustments so this is where we're
trying to go with this it's not
necessarily you need to stop eating the
sizzling and but just change the portion
size or add a little bit of something
else on top of it and if we could get to
the point again I think that computer
it's it's going to be challenging but if
you could get on to the point where we
can operate within the same language and
within the same set of references we
have a better potential of not having to
change kind of the paradigm of thinking
about nutrition
[Applause]
you